(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] In the French
Riviera lies a medieval town
that's held one industry at its very heart
for the last 300 years.
This is Grasse; this is the
world's capital of perfume.
This is the city of scents.
(speaking foreign language)
(romantic music)
- Some of the big names that
come from here like Chanel,
Chanel No. 5, Dior, of
course, and Louis Vuitton.
It's something that's understood here.
It's a community; it's a language;
it's something that people share.
- My name is Jessica Buchanan,
and I am an independent perfumer.
I came to Grasse for perfumery school.
So what I do is, in very simple contexts,
mixing together raw materials
for various different uses,
whether it's a perfume that
one would wear to, for example,
a candle.
I think to create a good
perfume, I like to allow
six months to a year.
This is a very creative process.
When I sit in front of the
perfumer's organ and create,
it's like sitting in front of
a piano and composing music.
Yeah, I think there's
something in the air here.
(upbeat piano music)